junk food also known as junk makes up
like 60 to the calories that we consume
in high income countries
um so the processed chips and dips the
you know the those little salami sticks
that you can buy at the drugstore they
have no business in the human digestive
tract uh the modern food industry has
been pumping chemicals like maltodextrin
polysorbate 80
carboxymethyl cellulose carrageenan
lecithins these artificially produced
flavor enhancers and emulsifiers into
the food System since the 1950s and 60s
they take stuff that isn't food and
makes it taste like food makes it soft
and moist and flavoursome makes it shelf
stable easy to ship cheaper to produce
and we we love it I mean it's it's very
carefully designed to appeal to our
primitive monkey brain that likes sweet
things and salty things and fatty things
and we love eating it but no business in
the human digestive tract